If you were a betting person, this wager probably wasn't for you.
But it turns out, one of the greatest fairytale stories in all of sports...
...came true May 2nd.
Leicester City pulled off the near impossible,...
...winning the British Premier League for the first time in the club's history...
...going from 14th place to the top in just one year.
With 5,000 to 1 odds at the start of the season,...
...their improbable run wasn't expected by many...
...especially since it's Leicester City's first top division championship...
...for a club that was founded in 1884.
Their previous best finish was second place in 1929.
There's still two matches to be played...
...which will likely become more of a victory tour for a set of unlikely champions.
With the win, the Foxes also gain entrance into a new club,...
...its first appearance in the UEFA Champions League group stage.
For NewsBeat Social, I'm Chad Carter.